the left finds a target-rich environment
in corporate cowards
the woked scolds come for Dave Chappelle
and Breck's its fate remains unclear i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
we have an enormous amount to get you
today and we will get to all of it we'll
just move straight through it we begin
today with the new crusade by the left
so the left is attempting to use
pressure politics in virtually every
area of American life we're going to
talk about how it is that the left uses
these pressure politics in areas of
American life to make American life a
lot worse because normally if you're
going to use pressure politics you use
it in you know politics right you direct
it politically you're going to pressure
your senator you're gonna pressure your
Congressman you're gonna organize phone
banking or you're gonna nominate
somebody to primary somebody or run
against somebody but we are now moving
into an era where so many people in
America now believe that government is
ineffective and ineffectual that instead
they're going to go to the commanding
heights of our culture and of our
business and they're going to try to use
those commanding Heights against their
fellow citizens now that's not illegal
obviously that isn't violate
prescriptions unlimited government but
it does change the natural tone and
tenor of how it is to live as an
American if you are simply going after
the commanding heights of Hollywood and
using it to cram down cultural
stereotypes about people you don't like
that does have an impact on American
life if you're going to the commanding
heights of corporate America and
demanding that corporate America do your
political bending that does have an
impact on how we live now again there's
a difference between the government
doing something like that and a
corporation doing something like that
we'll talk about that difference and why
it actually opens up some market
opportunities for conservatives as
corporations make themselves less
competitive on the American stage in
order to cater to the whims of the far
left it's very short-sighted corporate
policy but nonetheless it does polarize
us in heretofore unseen ways in America
okay so we begin today with the failure
of political blackmail so political
pressure politics have been used
obviously throughout the history of the
United States you try to pressure your
senator and the newest goal for the left
is to try and push Mitch McConnell maybe
they can shame Mitch McConnell into
passing some sort of gun control
legislation now there's a solution to
this for folks on the left you could
elect a majority
it could just elect a majority of
Democratic senators in fact you had a
majority of Democratic senators all the
way up through what 2014 and you could
elect a Democratic House which you
already have you could elect a
Democratic president in fact you had all
three of those branches you had the
Congress and you had the Senate and you
had the presidency from 2009 all the way
through 2011 early 2011 and you didn't
do anything I'm gun control so now you
see the press trying to push Mitch
McConnell into doing something and
they're trying to use president Trump's
vagary on gun control as sort of the
lever to get McConnell to do something
so you get the Washington Post editorial
board writing a full-page editorial I
mean that's straw dinerral a long
editorial today trying to push Mitch
McConnell suggesting that it's Mitch
McConnell's fault
that mass shootings are taking place
which is a rather large absurdity
considering again that mass shootings
have been taking place in the United
States for decades at this point
Columbine happened in the 1990s Mitch
McConnell was not the Senate Majority
Leader when a bevy of mass shootings
happened in 2009-2010 and Mitch
McConnell is not solely responsible for
the gun control policy in the United
States we had an assault weapons ban in
the United States the same assault
weapons ban Democrats are now pushing
from 1994 through 2004 and accomplished
precisely nothing so for all of the talk
about Mitch McConnell it ain't about
Mitch McConnell but this is normal
pressure politics okay this is just the
way politics works and there's nothing
particularly wrong with this I mean the
people who are pushing the agenda have
the wrong agenda they're pushing policy
that is impractical but this is sort of
normal politics as politics I guess is
supposed to work so the Washington Post
writes in editorial again entitled how
many more names will be added to the
list before Mitch McConnell acts on guns
and they just list a bunch of people who
are killed Saturday in Midland and
Odessa they said add those seven
individuals randomly slaughtered
Saturday by a shooter in the West Texas
cities of Midland and Odessa to the toll
of those lost to America's gun insanity
and then pose this question personal
again they are wrong on the politics
okay there's no such thing as quote
unquote gun insanity there are just
insane people with guns or evil people
with guns me owning a gun is not insane
you a law-abiding citizen owning a gun
to defend yourself is not insane it's
not gonna insanity again a gun is just a
tool to suggest that it's a part of
America's core Nicole Gunn insanity
is to create this miasmatic evil that
descends on America randomly when that
is not in fact the case but that's not
where the editorial board is going
obviously they say let's pose this
question what if there was a mass
shooting in the United States not once
or twice or four or six times monthly
but every single day a big one the kind
that electrifies social media and squats
for days on page one would that be
enough to move Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell from his insistent
inertia on gun safety what any volume of
bloodshed convinced the Kentucky
Republican that Congress faces a moral
imperative to act 38 people were slain
in three such shootings in August and
still Senate Republicans and President
Trump refused to act again this is the
old democratic saw which is that if you
don't agree with them on policy it's cuz
you don't care if people get shot and
that's a lie and it's nasty but it is
normal politics if you're directing it
at an elected senator and then they just
list off all of the people who are who
have been killed in a variety of mass
shootings they don't seem to care about
all the people getting killed in Chicago
because that is democratic govern they
say the list below far from
comprehensive is tragic in part because
it is so far from inevitable no no
single law would end gun violence but
there are reasonable obvious measures
that would help for example ban the sale
of military-grade assault weapons again
they say that's reasonable and obvious
didn't really have an impact on mass
shootings in the United States unneeded
by civilian they're a blight on the
nation they're ready availability a
national disgrace eliminating them would
slow the growth of this list it would
save lives again
you can't just assert this sort of stuff
you actually have to explain why and
then they just list off a bunch of names
and the names themselves are supposed to
be proof that the policy is is somehow
workable which of course is very silly
okay but again this is normal political
pressure and it's not working it's not
working and so many in the media have
now upped their game when it comes to
normal political pressure many on the
Left have up their game when it comes to
normal political pressure it's not just
pressuring Mitch McConnell to do what
you want it turns into concerted attacks
on people in deeply unfair ways so here
is an example yesterday yesterday there
was an article from Bloomberg that
resulted in a Texas conservative in leaf
Olson leaving the Department of Labor
why exactly was he forced to leave the
Department of Labor because he posted a
couple of times on Facebook making fun
of the alt-right
and mocking anti-semitism and Bloomberg
took that out of context to suggest that
he was alright and supported
anti-semitism I'll get to that story in
just one second first let's talk about
safety for just a minute so I'm somebody
who requires an enormous amount of
safety precautions unfortunately I get
an enormous number of death threats I
have stalkers there are lots of people
out there who are very very wild and
this means that I'm always concerned
about what's going on at my house and
this is why I rely on ring rings mission
is to make neighborhoods safer you might
already know about their smart video
doorbells cameras that protect millions
of people everywhere ring helps you stay
connected to your home anywhere in the
world so if there is a package delivery
or a surprise visitor you get an alert
you'll be able to see hear and speak to
them all from your phone this makes me
feel safer it makes my wife feels safer
I don't have to be home to know exactly
what's going on at the doorbell of my
house as a subscriber you have a special
offer on a ring welcome kit available
right now at ring.com
slash Ben the kit includes the ring
video doorbell doorbell - and a chime
Pro which is just what you need to start
building a ring of security around your
home today in fact I just upgraded all
of my ring kit because we're upgrading
security around my home you should to go
to ring.com slash Ben that's ring.com
slash Ben additional terms may apply
ring.com slash Ben and you have that
special offer available when you use
ring com slash man so as I say the
political pressure tactics start off in
the realm of normal and now they have
moved to the extreme so you have
Bloomberg printing this piece about leaf
Olson who's a trump Labor Department
official and here's how bloomberg
reports this a recently appointed Trump
Labor Department official with a history
of advancing controversial conservative
and faith-based causes in court has
resigned after revelations that he wrote
a 2016 Facebook post suggesting the
Jewish controlled media protects their
own it now sounds pretty bad doesn't it
except for it's obviously not what he is
saying he is obviously mocking all of
the people on the alt-right who were
suggesting this 2016 that Paul Ryan then
the Speaker of the House was going to
lose his congressional primary to Paul
Malin in open white supremacist and he
wrote this mocking this mocking
ridiculous Facebook post making fun of
the alright May he wrote establishment
insider RINO corporate to a Paul Ryan
was finally brought to heel in tonight's
primary election by an uprising of the
conservative masses of real America
eager for an authentic voice in
Washington instead of the same tired
globalist open borders pap they
been pushing on us since the elites
abandoned the people the guy just
suffered a massive historic emasculating
70-point victory let's see him in his
Georgetown cocktail party puppet masters
try to walk that one off and so
obviously he is mocking people who said
that Paul Malin was going to beat Paul
Ryan and then somebody wrote back to him
as a humorous reply he's a neocon too
you know and Leif Olson wrote back no
he's not Neil contr all Upper East Side
Zionist who don't golf on Saturday if
you know what I mean
right meaning again this is all making
fun of white supremacist and the
alt-right all of it all of it okay so
bloomberg reported this as though making
fun of the alt-right and anti-semitism
was actually anti-semitic so they could
get this guy fired the guy did end up
resigning okay so this is the shift from
normal political hits on like Mitch
McConnell to going out of your way to
deliberately read something wrong in
order to target somebody so that's bad
enough and then it goes even further and
that is the maligning of people you
disagree with not just by taking them
out of context but by literally calling
them terrorists so this is what's
happening in San Francisco within the
last 48 hours the San Francisco Board of
Supervisors declared the NRA
a domestic terrorist organization
getting this as an organization that is
a lobbying organization on behalf of
American citizens who wish to protect
their Second Amendment rights is now a
domestic terrorist organization so what
does that mean presumably you can raid
an NRA members home you can surveil an
NRA member I mean I really wonder why so
many gun owners are uneasy about red
flag laws when you have the the San
Francisco legislative body passing a
resolution officially labeling the NRA a
domestic terrorist organization is the
equivalent of labeling emily's list a
domestic terrorist organization on the
right district to supervisor Katherine
Stefani whose district includes the
marina and Presidio wrote the
declaration stating that their NRA quote
spreads propaganda that misinformed and
aims to deceive the public about the
dangers of gun violence in other words
they exercise their First Amendment
rights therefore they're a terrorist
organization they say that the NRA quote
musters its considerable wealth and
organizational strength to promote gun
ownership and incite gun owners to acts
of violence
there's no evidence that the NRA incites
gun owners to acts of violence that's
absurd and yes they do promote gun
ownership so do i I'm not a terrorist
if San Francisco is now in the business
of labeling people terrorists who
disagree with them now we are getting
into the realm of the dangerous so you
move from normal political manipulation
that is bad stuff they Mitch McConnell
stuff to a to abnormal political
manipulation members of the media
attacking people for precisely the
opposite of what they're saying to
openly labeling everybody to openly
labeling everybody who you don't like
some sort of terrorist the declaration
according to the San Francisco Board of
Supervisors reads quote all countries
have violence and hateful people but
only in America do we give them ready
access to assault weapons in large
capacity magazines thanks in large part
to the National Rifle Association's
influence
I mean how delightful house okay so all
of this is incredibly divisive and then
we get to the final step so that one is
bad because that is an actual board of
government labeling fellow-citizens
terrorists on the basis of their belief
system which is really nasty and let us
not forget that the entire left has
suggested that if you use inflammatory
language about the positions of people
on the left that you're inciting
violence against them so if you say that
Ilhan omar is a bad person an
anti-semite she says that you're
inciting violence against her if you
suggest that receded to leaves belief
system is wrong and nasty then you're
inciting violence against her in some
sort of way if you label everybody in
the United States who supports the
second amendment a terrorist apparently
that's totally okay in San Francisco if
you label the NR a which is again a
law-abiding First Amendment exercising
organization a terrorist organization
that's totally fine not inciting
violence in any way so all of that is
that but here's the thing all of that is
also unsuccessful and the fact is no
matter how much the San Francisco Board
of Supervisors yells at the NRA that is
not going to be an effective pressure
tactic because the NRA is the NRA the
fact is that Bloomberg could have
reported this about leaf Olson and if
leaf Olson and the Trump administration
had just stood strong and fought back
they really couldn't have gotten
anything done
Olson shouldn't of resign the fact is
that the Washington Post can write as
many editorials as it could possibly
want about Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell and he's not going to do their
bidding he is not going to care he's not
going to do their bidding because those
are not his constituents none of the
people who write for The Washington Post
editorial board are voters in his
date of Kentucky so this has pushed the
left to a new form of power politics and
that is the exercise of power politics
in the corporate sphere now there are
times when the exercise of power
politics in the corporate sphere is
actually good or justified right so
let's take an example so back in the
1960s and 1950s there were segregated
businesses and private people decided to
boycott those businesses in order to end
segregation so for example the
Woolworths counter in the early 1960s
the Woolworth lunch counter was
segregated and a bunch of civil rights
activists young black students for the
most part went into Woolworths and sat
down at the counter and then were abused
at the counter and this was such a
national scandal the world wars actually
voluntarily desegregated its counters
because they didn't want the blowback
right now those those people were acting
in courageous ways I don't have any
problem with that and as a general rule
it is quite possible that you can
pressure a corporation to quote-unquote
do the right thing but what we have now
seen is that that tactic has been
expanded beyond its use in specific
situations to simply castigate anybody
who disagrees with you on matters of
politics and to change corporate policy
from above and to change corporate
policy from above from the commanding
heights of business and this has grown
beyond specific instances of fighting
against discrimination and in - we need
to get our political preferences done by
any means necessary including activating
corporate bosses to do our bidding for
us today's example comes courtesy of
Walmart we'll explain why this is
actually quite divisive and polarizing
and why the end result is not going to
be exactly what the left thinks it is
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's be real about this you're
not getting enough sleep I'm not getting
enough sleep
nobody's getting enough sleep it's a
pressure filled time a lot of people are
worried about the economy a lot of
people are staying up nights worried
about the future politics and all the
rest well that means that when you do
lie down and you do want to be on the
best mattress upon which you can sleep
and this is where helix sleep comes in
my helix sleep mattress is tailored for
me and it's tailored for my wife
we took this two minute sleep quiz from
helix sleep they tailored a mattress
exactly to our specifications and then
they sent it to us in the mail we
unwrapped it we popped it on the bed it
was good to go it's super easy and
is incredibly comfortable no matter how
you sleep on the side on your back hot
sleeper whatever helix can make what
your body needs just go to helix sleep
calm slash Ben take their two minutes
sleep quiz and we'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life when I'm on
the road I can't sleep all that well
because I'm not on a helix sleep
mattress I can't wait to get home and
get on that helix sleep mattress you'll
feel the same way helix has a ten year
warranty you get to try it out for 100
nights risk-free and we even pick it up
for you if you don't love it but you
will helix is offering up to 125 bucks
off all mattress orders for our
listeners get up to 125 bucks off at
helix sleep comm slash Ben that's helix
sleep comm / Ben for up to 125 bucks off
your mattress order helix sleep comm /
Ben again that's helix sleep comm / Ben
okay so as I say there is a difference
between private businesses and
government so if government were to cram
down policy from above this would be a
constitutional problem when corporations
do it it's a cultural problem it's not a
constitutional problem it's a cultural
problem it's not a constitutional
problem because corporations can do
whatever they want lots of corporations
disagree with me that is their
prerogative it's America they can do
what they want Facebook can disagree
with me on policy that is their
prerogative Walmart can disagree with me
on policy that is their prerogative I'm
not calling for the regulation of
Walmart or Facebook or any of these
other corporations I am saying that the
left's use of corporations as a cudgel
is dangerous for the nature of American
political discourse and this is what the
left is increasingly doing now it
started off in the realm of secondary
boycotts so you saw the left do this
originally with Rush Limbaugh and they
did it with Sean Hannity and they did it
with Tucker Carlson they don't with
Laura Ingraham they tried to do with my
show what they do is they go to
corporations and they try to say to
those corporations how dare you sponsor
and subsidize speech with which we
disagree doesn't matter that you run
your advertising on a wide variety of
political shows if you sponsor then
Shapiro's program that means that you
must endorse everything ben shapiro says
now of course that isn't true but the
goal is to remove the profit incentive
for programs like mine by going after
advertisers now all of this is nonsense
right the fact is that those who claim
they're gonna boycott
you know the the coffee makers who are
on sean hannity show are totally full of
crap they we're never gonna boycott
those companies the people who sound off
for Media Matters
they really are
wielding enormous amounts of power they
can create a problem for your HR for
your PR department for like three days
and that's it but a lot of corporations
started caving to this sort of stuff
when they went after Rush Limbaugh's
advertisers when they went after Shawn's
advertisers or Tucker's I think and
create all sorts of problems and the
left saw that this was successful so
they've decided that they're going to
rely on corporate cowardice in order for
them to push their agenda now on a
broader level not just by going after
advertisers on programs like this one
which by the way is why you should
subscribe to the programs you like you
can subscribe to this program over at
Daley we're calm they've decided they're
going to go after corporations more
broadly and use those corporations to
cramdown policy that affects the entire
country again perfectly legal but it is
a sign of corporate cowardice that so
many corporate CEOs are falling for this
so corporate CEOs do control an enormous
amount of American Life we have these
big businesses they employ literally
millions of people I've been a big
defender of Walmart over the years and
the left has been attacking Walmart
saying they pay insufficient wages which
is not statistically true the left has
been attacking Walmart saying they want
to tax them out of business that's
Bernie Sanders his proposal I haven't
over here defending Walmart right but
Walmart does control an enormous amount
of America's industry obviously and this
is true for a wide variety of
corporations so if the left cannot
capture government if they cannot get
elected to positions of power instead
they figure they will capture the
boardrooms by threatening action against
CEOs by threatening action against
corporations by threatening to make a PR
stink if they do not get what they want
now all it would take is corporations to
just say I'm not gonna do it oh you know
we're here to do we're here to sell
product that's what we do and if you
don't like those products that's on you
man if you don't like the products that
we sell your few you can feel free to
shop elsewhere but now because of the
media pressure because of the left's
pressure political pressure the threat
of legislation from the government what
you're starting to see is corporations
seeking safety behind the shield of
either government regulation or positive
PR from the press that is what they're
doing now that is a business driven
decision in the short term in the long
term it's a bad business decision and
it's bad for the culture so in the short
term that decision is driven by a desire
to avoid scrutiny our desire to avoid
political blowback in the long term
you're removing faith in our corporate
institution
which are not designed to do good they
are designed to provide product they're
designed to provide you products and
services you're the one who's supposed
to do good with the products and
services it's not up to a paternalistic
CEO to decide exactly which products you
should consume it is up to you to decide
which products you should consume it and
again this is different from Woolworths
counts or boycotts which were designed
to stymie actual discriminatory policy
by corporations that I think is morally
justifiable I think that if you are
going after Walmart and suggesting that
Walmart cannot distribute or sell
ammunition because it makes you mad I'm
having a hard time understanding what
that has to do with them discriminating
against black people how that's
comparable in any way for example okay
so why is this relevant well because on
Tuesday Walmart announced that after its
current inventory is depleted it will
cave to the demands of far-left
activists and stop selling handgun
ammunition and ammunition commonly used
and other popular semi-automatic
firearms now again let me reiterate this
is their decision they can do this
legally they can I'm not calling for
regulation of Walmart I'm not calling
for a boycott of Walmart I am suggesting
that Walmart is making a corporate
driven decision that is driven by PR it
is not driven by good business and it's
not gonna be good for the culture in the
long run Walmart also stated it was
requesting that customers shoe carrying
guns openly in their roughly forty seven
hundred stores as well as its Sam's club
stores in states that permit open carry
according to CNN this is daily wire
reporting Walmart CEO Doug McMillon
issued a memo to employees on Tuesday in
which he started by citing the mass
shooting in El Paso and Dayton in August
as well as further shootings in Midland
and Odessa Texas
he continued quote we've been listening
to a lot of people inside and outside
our company as we think about the role
we can play in helping to make the
country feel safer it is clear to us
that the status quo is unacceptable
Macmillan noted that Walmart had already
ceased selling ar-15s raising the age of
limit to purchase a firearm or ammo 2:21
required a green light on the background
check for purchase instead of the
absence of red light which is required
by federal law among other steps then he
wrote quote today we're sharing the
decisions we've made that go further
after selling through our current
inventory commitments we will
discontinue sales of short-barrel rifle
ammunition such as the two to three
caliber and the five five six caliber
that well commonly used in some hunting
rifles can also be used in large
capacity clips
military-style weapons again no
definition of what a military style
weapon is here he says we'll sell
through and discontinue handgun
ammunition will discontinue handgun
sales in Alaska marking our complete
exit from handguns Macmillan
acknowledged that the stores would still
offer long barrel deer rifles and
shotguns cited incidents where
individuals have entered Walmart stores
attempting to make a statement and test
our response and then says we are
respectfully requesting that customers
no longer openly carry firearms into our
stores or Sam's clubs in states where
open carry is permitted unless they are
authorized law enforcement officers
Macmillan stated he was sending letters
to the White House and congressional
leadership encouraging them to implement
stronger background checks and the
removal of weapons from those who have
been determined to pose an imminent
danger he concluded the status quo is
unacceptable okay so this is
corporations that are now being
activated in political ways John
Bartlett who is the Walmart executive VP
of corporate affairs told reporters
quote we feel like we are striking a
responsible balance between the
interests of law-abiding citizens who
are exercising their legal rights and
the safety concerns of our associates
and customers again this is their
prerogative however it is important to
note a couple of things one they will
not escape he woke scolds the left will
come after them anyway - they are doing
a heavy damage to our culture in a
general way which I will explain in just
one second first let's talk about the
underwear that currently graces your
toughies I can tell you the underwear
that currently graces this magnificent
took us is Tommy John underwear it is
truly comfortable it is durable it
really is first-rate Tommy John doesn't
just claim to be the most comfortable
underwear on the planet they actually
have the stats to back it up like this
number over seven million that is the
number of pairs of Tommy John underwear
they have sold with 96% of their
customers rating them with four stars or
greater with Tommy John's revolutionary
underwear the legs never ride up the
waist bands never roll down and Tommy
John is more than just underwear they've
got 750 products online such as
supersoft loungewear polo shirts and
apparel Tommy John is so sure you're
gonna love the fit and feel that it's
all backed by their best pair you'll
ever wear or it's free guarantee that
means if you don't love your first pair
you will get a full refund refund -
Tommy John no adjustment needed hurry
over - Tommy John comm / Ben right now
get 20% off your first order that is
Tommy John comm / Ben for 20% off
John comm / Ben go check them out right
now again that's Tommy John comm / Ben
and you getting 20% off that first word
I promise you these underwear are
fantastic Tommy John comm / Ben okay so
there are a few things that that Walmart
is not thinking through here one they're
not thinking through whether the left is
gonna leave them alone the answer of
course is no a bevy of Democrats then
went on Twitter after this announcement
and suggested the Walmart needed to do
more Comeau harris said that she thought
walmart should stop selling guns utterly
she said yeah I do it's not that
everyone needs to stop selling guns but
there need to be checks and balances
well she's gonna have to explain why it
is that Walmart shouldn't sell guns but
other people should presumably should
like for everybody to stop selling guns
congressman Tim Ryan of Ohio said I
think if you keep it to hunting rifles
and those kind of things I think that's
appropriate how long is that going to
last
five moments exactly five minutes and
there had been a bunch of Democrats who
had called on Walmart to change its
policy so that is not going to stop the
locals from coming for Walmart so this
is Walmart trying to buy off in the
short term all of the Democrats to
basically stop criticizing them and
leave them alone they don't want the PR
hit of continuing to sell guns and that
is again their prerogative but it is
short-sighted because it ain't gonna
stop you can keep feeding that alligator
it will eat you okay you will be eaten
okay so that is point number one point
number two if you continue along these
lines where major corporations are
expected to insert themselves in
hot-button political debates and then
take sides in hot-button political
debates the predictable and more than
that where the policies that they cram
down from above on customers our
policies that favor one political side
what you will end up with is an entire
other side of the industry so for every
Walmart that fails to sell ammunition as
they used to there will be another store
that crops up that sells ammunition and
this is why again I'm not going to
pretend that government regulation and
Walmart doing this are they're not
obviously I've made that distinction
several times here but what you're going
to end up with inevitably and this is
the direction we're moving as a country
is separate stores for conservatives and
liberals is separate TV channels for
conservatives and liberals separate
everything for conservatives and
liberals all the common spaces we once
used to
habet will go away because once you
expect corporations to become the
leading political players because they
have enormous power to shape American
life you should not be surprised when
other corporations form to fight back
against all of that the former Walmart
CEO he bill Simon he said yesterday that
in the end the only thing that will
solve the problem is gun control in DC
and this is why when people say that big
business is Republican or big business
is concerned if it's not true a big
business is profit seeking ok when that
means sometimes is there rent seeking
from DC and so they don't want to have
to take a position on this and so
they're gonna call on Washington DC to
change policy just so that they don't
actually have to make decisions about
any of this or leave it to the customers
to make decisions about any of this
here's bill Simon former Walmart's CEO
when you see a major retailer like
Walmart take a move like this though do
you think it does add pressure to
lawmakers to try and come to the table
and have discussions I think that's the
only thing that's gonna that's going to
get to solve the problem we have a we
have a crisis that has to be dealt with
in us that would by sitting down
petitions to retailers gosh and maybe
they make some people feel good because
they feel like they need to take action
but they won't solve the problem okay
now that's true but it didn't stop
Walmart from what I'm quote trying to
solve the problem by inserting itself
into the issue I said so that really
should be the normal answer of CEOs now
I understand that what the left has been
trying to do is suggest the capitalism
is itself the problem there's this real
push over the New York Times a bunch of
other major publications suggesting the
capitalism and free markets themselves
are the problems and that we need a new
type of capitalism a quote unquote
responsible capitalism what they mean by
that is they want retailers not to give
customers choice they want real aid
retailers to act as sort of guardian
angels toward the American public not to
stop selling products that inevitably do
damage to people like cigarettes for
example but products that can be used
for good or can be used for ill they
want the corporation's to decide well
they're not gonna like it if the shoes
on the other foot right I mean if the
corporation's decide the other way to
ban a bunch of products the left loves
then all of a sudden it'll be well how
could these corporations be cramming
down their politics on us right but when
it comes to them cramming down their
politics using the commanding heights of
the economy
then they are not only fine with it they
are very much in favor of it again the
predictable result is going to be a
massive large-scale division in American
life and it's not going to stop at
Walmart so Andrew Ross Sorkin who writes
for the New York Times and also as a
commentator on CNBC he has a column in
which he praises Walmart's CEO for
injecting themselves into this gun
debate and then he suggests that this
should happen with all businesses randy
says midday Tuesday Doug McMillon
Walmart's chief executive sent me a
surprise email he shared a series of
policies the company was about to make
public about combating gun violence
since the mass shooting that killed 22
people and one of his El Paso stores
last month mr. McMullin email was a
reply of sorts to an open letter I had
written to him along with the outcry he
heard from scores of Americans calling
on him to use his leverage as leader of
the country's largest retailer to create
a model for more responsible gun selling
practices now Macmillan and Walmart were
not breaking the law in the first place
right they were abiding by the law but
the idea was that they were supposed to
do more they were supposed to be our
leaders the corporations it's always
amusing to hear folks on the Left who
are constantly ripping on big business
and corporations talk about these people
being our moral leaders weird how that
morphs really quickly right Elizabeth
Warren moves from corporations are the
evil scourge of our society - but they
really should be setting gun policy
shouldn't they it's pretty amusing about
face but ross sorkin wants more not just
from walmart he says until now many top
executives in corporate America with
some notable exceptions refuse to
acknowledge the rules they could play in
curbing the epidemic of gun violence
they invariably pointed to politicians
in Washington as the ones who are
responsible for solving the crisis for
example Nelson this examples and Mason
example Isis for example al Kelly the
chief executive of visa
whose network has been used repeatedly
to carry out mass murders really visas
been used repeatedly to carry out mass
murders how where people like slicing
each other's throats with with the
actual credit cards because if visas did
not engage in illegal transactions I'm
not sure how you blame them for mass
murder his al Kelly the chief executive
of visa has ducked any attempts to even
discuss what his company could do to
help mr. Kelly likes to say as he did
earlier this summer we are in the
business of facilitating legal commerce
that's what we do our job is not to set
or interpret but to follow the law this
is the proper answer this is what
economy is set up to do this is what
free markets are supposed to do give you
the choices to the products and services
you wish to consume make you the
consumer responsible for where you shop
make you the consumer responsible for
the kind of products that you decide to
buy instead what many on the Left would
like to do is lobby the heads of these
corporations to set policy for you and
they want to do so not at the behest of
the consumer because there was not vast
consumer outcry against Walmart its
stock was not dropping and instead what
they would like to do is create
manufactured media controversy and then
suggest that the CEOs should step in
where the political bosses have failed
to act so these are the new pressure
tactics right basically you use a form
of corporate blackmail to go after
corporate figures and then use them to
culturally cram down what you could not
achieve politically as I say all of that
is perfectly legal is it good for the
country no it's not good for the country
why well imagine a world in which visa
sets policy for exactly who they will do
business with imagine a world in which
visa says we are just not going to
process your transaction all the credit
card companies left gets what it wants
all the credit card companies say we are
not going to process your transactions
if they're not transactions with which
we agree that's going to get in some
really dicey territory incredibly
quickly because let's say for example
that you want to give charity to your
synagogue or your church and your
synagogue or your church does not
perform same-sex marriages for example
and visa says ok well we are not going
to allow you to give charity using our
credit card because we disagree with
your church's policies okay is that a
good thing or a bad thing
you have to separate and what you will
end up with is separate chains of
Commerce politically speaking the
biggest problem in the country right now
everyone talks about it is political
polarization but the Left solution for
political polarization is to not let you
engage in any business in any commerce
unless you agree with them they would
let let's not pretend that they just
want Walmart to stop selling ammo what
they want is for everyone to stop
selling ammo and everyone to stop
selling guns well that's not going to
happen instead what you're gonna have
happen is people who set up entire
chains of Commerce that are based
outside of the common system we
currently hold I'll tell you what will
happen people like me will set up a
conservative credit card that is
designed and oriented so that
conservatives
and patronized conservative businesses
and get points back to conservative
causes and we'll do this
not because we want to but out of
necessity what you will end up with is
not people failing to buy guns you'll
have people buying guns in cash which
actually makes it a lot harder for
people to track the transactions so if
you're on the left and you like gun
control that ain't smart well you're
gonna end up with is a world in which we
have entirely separate spheres of life
based on your political orientation
because we force corporations into
taking sides that is where we are going
and that is the future that a lot on the
Left want right they they're very
excited that corporate CEOs are now
getting involved in these fights now in
the long term what's gonna end up
happening is that these corporations are
gonna cut themselves off from half the
American public because there will be a
reaction and the reaction will be I'm
not gonna shop there anymore by half of
it so in the in the moment they're
figuring that conservatives will be
saying what about all of this
and they'll just continue to shop at
Walmart and that's probably true but
here's the reality if they did not stop
selling ammo left us would have
continued shopping at Walmart does they
like to and moan about Walmart but
then they go and chop there every day
but the corporations in injecting
themselves into these sorts of scenarios
are going to create an alternative line
of Commerce and it's not actually it may
be fine on a free-market level again
free markets work but it ain't gonna be
great on a cultural level for people to
shop separately to go to different
stores things are gonna get nastier and
nastier more and more polarized we'll
talk more about this in just one second
first listen it's it's really tough to
find good people to staff your company
for example we have a producer here
Austin and Austin is good at a great
many things but he also happens to be a
Cubs fan now what I prefer to employ a
Cubs fan of course I would not prefer to
employ a Cubs fan I'm a White Sox fan
also Austin has a deep and abiding level
of calm and patronizing cynicism that
alienates everyone who works within a
30-foot sphere of Austin now he's not
actually really cynical he's actually a
really nice guy but he's so quiet that
you feel like he's judging you all the
time let's say I wanted to replace
Austin the place I would go will be zip
recruiter calm slash daily wire zip
recruiter sends your job posting to over
100 of the web's leading job boards but
they don't stop there
as applications come in Zipporah courier
analyzes each one and then they
spotlight the top candidates so you
never miss a great match zip recruiter
is so effective that four out of five
employers who post on zipper
get equality candidate through the site
within the very first day right now my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter dot-com slash daily wire that
is zip recruiter comm slash at Dai ly WI
re zip recruiter comm slash daily wire
zip recruiter is indeed the smartest way
to hire zip recruiters comm slash daily
wire they're they're one of our favorite
advertisers especially because I can
always use their advertisements to make
my employees deeply uncomfortable on
every possible level already in just a
second I want to get to more cultural
polarization because the the attempts to
polarize us using politics right those
are pretty much gonna fail in the
political sphere but then to do it on
the corporate level that is succeeding
and then there's another area where the
left seeks to polarize and that isn't
the entertainment of rail we'll get to
that in just one second first you have
to go and subscribe over at daily wired
icon so as you may have been hearing
during this show it is deeply important
that you subscribe to the programs that
you like why because the left would like
to remove all profit incentive from
those programs by going after
advertisers by going after corporations
by suggesting that we cannot work in the
normal business sphere right and it's
disgusting and it's absurd the way you
protect yourself against that to make
sure that we can continue to bring you
the content that you love is you go to
daily wire calm and you spend $9.99 a
month or 99 bucks a year when you got
the ninety nine bucks a year annual
subscription they also get this the very
greatest in beverage vessels they
leftist here is hot or cold tumbler go
check it out
right now it is indeed magnificent it
really helps us out and make sure that
we can continue to function as a
business and keep our otherwise
unemployable employees employed so go
check us out right now at daily wired
comm we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
so as I say what we're going to end up
with is a cultural polarization and the
CEOs think that they can buy off the
left and they are so wrong here
they are so wrong so MSNBC yesterday was
cheering Walmart's decision it's a big
victory I mean imagine a a supposedly
first amendment press organization
cheering a corporate decision to crack
down basically on some of its own
consumers here is MSNBC cheering this
this is a massive move if you consider
what an enormous retailer Walmart is
what an enormous employer it is and we
can sit here in a newsroom and say this
is a very clear-cut issue look it's not
a clear-cut issue gun culture is a
really important part of America so I
for wal-mart sees more of America than
any other business without a doubt so to
see Doug McMillon the current CEO sort
of stand up and step up at a time like
this this is a massive move oh it's a
mess it's they're so happy about this
they're so happy about this you know
pressuring corporations into doing their
bidding this is what the left would like
to do and again they can do this because
if you're a corporate boss what you want
is no controversy that's really what you
want is no controversy and you want to
piss off the fewest number of people now
what they mistake is that everybody in
the media who talks has any real impact
on who Shops at Walmart if that were the
case Walmart would have been bankrupt 15
years ago but CEOs are risk-averse and
they figure the easiest way to avoid
risk is how much money didn't make off
selling ammo maybe a few million bucks a
year how what's the risk of the media
coming down on us maybe a few million
bucks a year what they don't understand
is that when you shape the overall
culture so that people feel alienated
from your business because they feel
like you're taking sides your long-term
risk is actually pretty significant and
if you think that the Democrats are
gonna lay off you you are totally wrong
so let's take an example Facebook has
been attempting to make nice with a lot
of folks on the Democratic side of the
aisle and in helping Senator Ron Wyden
suggested today that he wants to send
Mark Zuckerberg to prison he said that
he wants to send Mark Zuckerberg to
prison for what what what exactly would
the crime be he unclear he just knows he
doesn't like Mark Zuckerberg
he says Mark Zuckerberg has repeatedly
lied to the American people about
privacy I think he ought to be held
personally accountable which is
everything from financial fines - and
let me underline this the possibility of
a prison term hey if corporate CEOs
believe
that there will not be a push by members
of the Democratic Party to jail CEOs who
do not do what they want them to do
they're wrong
okay the far left is not going to stop
with oh we're so happy the Walmart
stopped selling ammo do you really think
that that's the only problem the left
has with Walmart because if so you
haven't been watching very closely hey
now this is also infected the cultural
sphere so the left there there are
several major institutions in American
life where there are commanding heights
now again for the ninth time this show
there is a difference between the
government which is an elected body with
delegated powers to defend our rights
invading those rights and the cultural
decay that happens when other common
institutions break down I'm talking
about the latter yeah this is not a
question of regulating Walmart or
regulating Hollywood or anything like
that but when the left decides to
weaponize cultural institutions that
alienates a lot of people it creates
polarization it makes it impossible for
us to have conversations together so the
latest victim of this is Dave Chappelle
so I don't know if you've seen
Chappelle's special but Chappelle's news
special is insanely politically
incorrect I mean incredibly so he mocks
his own audience for being too woke
there's one point where he says in the
middle of the special he says I'm gonna
do an imitation and then he says or you
tweeted something bad five years ago and
now I'm gonna come after you and destroy
your career Who am I and everybody
thinks oh well you know that's the media
and he says that's you that's all of you
and that's right I mean Chappelle was
correct about this Chappelle also calls
out in specific I mean he specifically
calls out the LGBTQ lobbying
organizations for going after comedians
and for trying to destroy their careers
and he specifically cites the Kevin Hart
situation he very hilariously states
that Kevin Hart who he's known for years
is basically a perfect human even well
for tweets shy of perfect he talks about
Kevin Hart's career basically being
destroyed or at least significantly
damaged at the height of his career
aspirations how's the Oscars by the
wokes gold and then he talks at length
he does a riff about abortion and his
riff about abortion ends up being a kind
of her life and he says that he doesn't
care whether a woman has an abortion but
if the woman decide if it's the woman's
choice and only the woman's choice that
men shouldn't have to pay for the child
support which is a
very common argument that is made by by
sort of cynical pro-lifers and then he
says or maybe we have the logic of this
whole thing entirely wrong the left has
gone absolutely ape bleep about this I
mean they have gone insane about this
and the critics hate this Chappelle's
meant no Chappelle used to be these sort
of consensus best comedian living and
there a lot of great comedians Chappelle
was loved by everybody everybody enjoyed
his routine now however he has done
something something very bad and the
reviewers are very very angry about it
and so Chappelle must be punished don't
you understand the commanding heights of
Hollywood must prevent the accession of
people like Dave Chappelle because Dave
Chappelle has crossed too many lines now
Dave Chappelle is intersectional right
he is a black man and this means that he
also makes jokes about white people
they're very very harsh jokes about the
heroin epidemic and white folks and all
the rest of this but he is a gun-toting
black man who makes jokes about abortion
and LGBTQ lobbying organizations and
this means he must be excised in
Hollywood has to be the commanding
heights of Hollywood have to be used on
behalf of one particular points of view
and if they are not then the woke scolds
in the media and in Hollywood will come
after them so Dave Chappelle is now the
target of these wilkes goals so vice
reviewed Chappelle's Chappelle's special
like this quote now he chooses to
blatantly ignore the historic criticism
against his style of comedy and new loud
and clear criticism from the trans
community paste magazine called his
special boring hypocritical and out of
touch there's a bunch of it basically he
had for a long time 0% at Rotten
Tomatoes from critics why because
critics are no longer reviewing the
quality of an act instead they're
reviewing the woken us of an act which
is how hannah Gadsby who is the least
funny person who has ever lived
i mean i'm talking about the least funny
human being who has ever lived there are
there there are there are human beings
who live in caves in isolation who have
never heard a joke and are not properly
properly socialized were more funny than
hannah Gadsby she has 100% ratings on
Rotten Tomatoes Dave Chappelle was at
zero percent on Rotten
why because he violated the rules he
violated the rules on Rotten Tomatoes
it was slate right even cool kangin
slate wrote like dropping in on a
rascally uncle who doesn't know or
doesn't care how much he's just he's
disappointing you
Alyson Herman of the ringer said sticks
and stones is designed to generate
inflammatory coverage it's a symbiotic
cycle with no end in sight it's become
the last thing a beloved provocateur
should ever want to be predictable okay
though
they are reviewing him for his proper
acquiescence to the struggle session
maoist left views of comedy he must be
destroyed he must be destroyed it's it's
really it's really quite pathetic
and now the audience reviews of the of
the special are very high people who
like Chappelle like Chappelle and people
who don't even watch the pail all that
often are looking at this and going I
can't believe that you'd said that out
loud
but the fact is that Hollywood will not
allow this sort of thing to go forward
and so Chappelle must be destroyed
so Chappelle is now on the target list
the same way that Kevin Hart was on the
target list it's the same reason why you
saw in the last 48 hours attempts by
folks in Hollywood to try and out
everybody in Beverly Hills who's going
to a Trump fundraiser because everyone
must think alike or be excised the
commanding heights of the culture the
commanding heights of Corporate America
and the commanding heights of politics
must all be occupied by folks who agree
with the left now in the political realm
the good news is we have things called
elections and so we can just say no in
the corporate realm it is very difficult
to convince corporate CEOs that they
ought to listen to their own customers
as opposed to the woke scold checkmarks
crowd on Twitter and in the
entertainment media that is particularly
true there's Britain now so here I'm a
stop and say good on Whoopi Goldberg
Whoopi Goldberg actually said the right
thing yesterday on the view she was
talking about this push by Debra Messing
and Eric McCormack these stars of Will
and Grace to out all of the donors to
President Trump in the Beverly Hills
area and Whoopi Goldberg says the right
thing idea of who you don't want to work
with is your personal business do not
encourage people to print out lists
because the next list that comes out
your name will be on and then people
will be coming after you in this country
people can vote for who they want to
that is one of the great rights of this
country you don't have to like it we
don't go after people because we don't
like who they voted for we don't go
after them that way we can talk about
issues and stuff but we don't print out
lists okay good for Whoopi Goldberg and
we need more of this from the left now
it's funny I said basically all of this
on Twitter this morning and the left
went nuts how dare you how dare you you
are suggesting that this is just like
government action you're trying to cram
down on CEOs what you want okay absolute
sheer horse pucky I'm suggesting that
these CEOs can do precisely what they
want but there will be ramifications to
it and it will not be good for the
country
I will Wilkinson who writes for I
believe Huffington Post sometimes you
said the complaint here is really the
businesses cater to customers but the
hard-right minority is accustomed to
political institutions rigged to stymie
majority opinion and they want
everything to be like that really is the
majority opinion in the United States
that Walmart should not be able to sell
product that's legal is that the
majority opinion in the United States or
is that a minority opinion in the United
States that is using the power of social
media and blue checkmarks and MSNBC to
cram down their preferred policy on CEOs
again my big concern here is that at
least politics is built so that we can
have conversations and then we can
decide how those conversations turn out
because we do this thing called voting
it's really great and then we have
checks and balances to prevent people
from simply running roughshod over other
people's rights but the realm of
corporate America is not designed for
that the realm of Hollywood is not
designed for that and when people wonder
why it is that Republicans conservatives
focus so much on politics the answer is
at least we have a voice there at least
we can push back there in Hollywood
which is universally staffed by
Democrats there is really no way to push
back there Dave Chappelle will find
himself on the outs or he will change
right or he will or he will do it as
ease on sorry has done and say some
politically incorrect things but say
them in politically correct ways I
Hughley their caved to the crowd or he
will be destroyed and in corporate
America as long as corporate CEOs decide
that they are going to cower in fear at
the woke left then there's not much the
Conservatives can really do about any of
that which is why I say that
corporations need to stand up on their
hind legs and say our job is to provide
goods and services to willing customers
if you want to change the law change law
but we are not going to change
based on your policy preferences today
that is not what we are doing as a
general rule if they don't do that then
things will get more polarized and it
will become more more important for
Republicans to keep the levers of
government you wonder why Republicans
are so rabid about elections these days
that would be why they feel like the
government is the only area of life
where they still get a say and they feel
like if the left takes over the
government they're gonna use precisely
the same logic that they have used with
corporations and with Hollywood and
they're going to cram down their
opinions on everybody else using the
power of the government gun this time
not just the power of a few loud
speakers in the faces of abject lis
craven CEOs okay time for a quick thing
I like and then a quick thing that I
hate so things that I like today so in
my spare time
my copious free time I am a fan of
fantasy novels somebody in the office
I'd recommended terry goodkind's
Wizard's First Rule admit it took me a
little bit of time to get into it this
book I believe is from the early 90s I
think and it took me maybe 150 200 pages
to get into it I have not finished the
book yet so I don't know if it ends well
but I will say that it is entertaining
and it definitely carries you so the
book is Wizard's First Rule by Terry
Goodkind
the writing style takes a little bit to
adjust to because at the beginning is
kind of awkwardly written but then it
definitely gets better and more
interesting as it goes on so if you're
into good fancy novels then try that one
out Wizard's First Rule by Terry
Goodkind and thanks to producer Anthony
for that particular recommendation okay
time for a quick thing that I hate all
righty so today the New York Post is
reporting that representative Ilhan
Omar's husband wants a divorce after
this bombshell report about her having
an affair with DC political consultant
Tim my net now that in and of itself is
a thing - hey whenever families break up
regardless of whether you like the
people involved that is really terrible
for the kids she has three kids that
cannot be good for her I will point out
that if a Republican congresswoman were
involved in this sort of scandal right
now it would be on the front pages of
every newspaper in America because L hen
Tamar has a beloved figure on the left
however then everybody sort of ignores
this or pretends that it's politically
incorrect to talk about it the fact is
that it raises serious moral questions
about her character obviously she is
breaking she is a married woman still
she
alleged they allegedly separated in
March and Omar asked her see to divorce
her around that time because she didn't
want to file the papers but her she
refused telling her if she wanted a
divorce you should do it herself
according to sources talking to the near
post and then after Tim my Nets wife
filed bombshell divorce papers claiming
that her spouse was having an affair
with Omar her see was angry and he said
that he was made to look a fool and he
is considering filing for divorce again
the media coverage of this I mean the
New York Post is covering and I've not
seen it covered in any mainstream
publication again imagine this were
nikki Haley imagined that this were
Sarah Palin I imagine the media would be
covering the story incredibly incredibly
differently okay we'll be back here
later today with much much more we
didn't get a chance to get to brexit we
didn't get a chance to get to the
developments in Hong Kong so we'll get
those get to those later today is why I
should subscribe over at Daily wire
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Stevens audio is mixed by
Mike Caro Mina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright day Lee Weyer
2019 hey folks its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show whether it's
about race about guns of the climate
brexit or the economy the left has
learned to tell simple stories to get
what they want power we'll talk about
that plus solve all your problems in the
mailbag on the Andrew Klavan show I'm
Andrew clay